ça tourne ça tourne super aujourd'hui
dans votre Calendrier de l'Avent 100 %
éelinois on parle
bière pour la première je vous emmène à
bois d'Arc la brasserie au cloc vous
propose une cinquantaine de bières
différentes allant de la plus douce à la
plus corsée je prends des bougie je sais
pas pourquoi au cloc c'est l'histoire de
trois amis qui ont décidé de se lancer
dans la bière pose les bougies ma
préférée c'est la side effect c'est une
triple forte en Malte avec des notes de
caramel vous m'en direz des nouvelles
pour la deuxième elle porte bien son nom
on va prendre la petite sœur c'est une
brasserie à Sartrouville vous pouvez y
retrouver tous les classiques blondes
Rous brune mais aussi des bières de
saison comme Noël par exemple la bière
de Noël ça c'était de l'impro ça et pour
finir on a la district à mole avec une
grande variété de bière à commander en
ligne ou à venir chercher en drive je
vais m'asseoir là toutes les bières sont
disponibles à un prix moyen de 3 € plus
que de la bière une ambiance yvelinoise
à glisser sous le sapin en rapport au
sapin que j'ai au-dessus de moi et bien
entendu à consommer avec modération
bonne fête et je crois que je suis je
suis fait pour ça en fait là